no horrible teaching experience I know
you've had eight jobs in the last year
you probably guess what my question is
gonna be where do I get my stamina four
months if you last that long it'll be
longer than most of my permanent hires
really nobody's gonna crack open a book
and there
why do they like this so it'll steal for
the engineering Club I'd like to enter
this the fifth annual underwater
robotics competition so you want to go
up against the best tech schools in the
country says they Scout for internships
and jobs you guys got some ground to
make up the other teams will have more
money than you
so you're still short four hundred and
thirty two dollars and 50 percents and
my man made a couple ice creams on the
way in and I have an ice cream too late
to change okay we got to find cheap
creative ways to build this thing how do
we fix it you gotta stop it sleep what's
small and really absorbent
every day in a hundred ways they are
told that they are worthless that they
are beyond hope more they need me then
why I start to wonder am I gonna bet
them down you remember everything you
said I'm not giving up
well we're not giving now he's full of
surprises I saw something like this in a
horror movie one Virginia Tech MIT and
Carl Hayden Community High School RIF we
couldn't do this without you sir
finish line always appears think about
how far away the confidence and
everything that we've gained that no one
can take away what we start out together
she is do talk to her are we looking at
a teachable moment sure are they trying
to show them a lesson about rejection I
think just slapped me hard I think women
are all horrible teachers
you